check out Pippa Middleton in London on  Tuesday her dazzling engagement ring on  full display et can confirm Pippa just  got engaged the 32 year old was all  smiles in this knee length and  appropriately white eyelet dress and  look closely her ring hands clutching  her rustic brown purse it is hard not to  notice that sparkler she has lunch  Pippa's boyfriend James Matthews popped  the question on Sunday in England's Lake  District and her sister Kate and Prince  William could not be more ecstatic for  the couple a kensington palace  spokesperson tells ET the Duke and  Duchess of Cambridge are absolutely  delighted with the new HIPAA and James  are currently planning to walk down the  aisle next year